Marvel Studios is apparently taking a
bit of a breather this summer pressing
pause on its production schedule after
wrapping up phase 3 of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe the slowdown seems
set to start after the launches of
Avengers endgame in April and spider-man
far from home in July taking to Twitter
in late February Deadpool co-creator Rob
Liefeld offered an intriguing
observation about where he thinks the
MCU is heading beyond 2019 as the writer
and artist pointed out after endgame and
far from home it looks as though it will
be about a year before another Marvel
film is rolled out into theaters as
Liefeld wrote in a Twitter post still
wrapping my head around the fact that
there are no Marvel movies currently
filming so a full-year absent Marvel
films following spider-man after far
from home makes its debut the next
scheduled release date for Marvel's
studio film is May 1st 2020 and as of
the start of March 2019 it's not
publicly known what that movie is going
to be whatever it is that leaves roughly
10 months between the spider-man sequel
and Marvel's mystery project prolific
comic book writer Mark Miller the writer
behind influential properties like
wanted kick-ass & Kingsman the Secret
Service joined in on the conversation on
Twitter replying to Liefeld's original
tweet with his own thoughts
the writer noted that this might be the
first time in over ten years that
there's been this wide of a gap between
MCU releases he also argues that it's a
good thing calling the apparent cool
down quote a wise move he explained this
take further by writing they felt
relentless for a while and a wee wait
will only build anticipation what's
weirder is we're still not entirely sure
what's coming while Miller has never
been too closely involved with Marvel on
the moviemaking side he's no stranger to
working with the company's characters
having written four such series as
ultimate Fantastic Four ultimate x-men
and Marvel Knights spider-man among
others so while he does possess some
insider insight he seems to be as in the
dark about Marvel Studios specific plans
as any other fan in 2014 Marvel Studios
released a massive roadmap for the next
few years of MCU content culminating in
the two-part infinity war and the since
scrapped inhuman
movie now that we're reaching the end of
that sequence the future of the series
feels more unknown than ever the secrecy
makes sense it's been pointed out that
revealing the MCU future plans before
endgames release could potentially spoil
the events of endgame especially if that
climactic movie kills off an Avenger or
two for good with that in mind the
studio plane thinks close to the vest is
understandable and there are probably
some benefits to a short hiatus - while
superhero fatigue hasn't kicked in with
audiences yet it remains a real
possibility and Marvel could be wise to
take a moment after endgame to enjoy a
victory lap before getting audiences
excited for its next few dozen movies
for over a decade now the studio has
been cranking out films at a blistering
pace kicking off the MC use first phase
with six movies in the span of four
years for Phase two and beyond the
company picked up the pace seemingly
pushing its luck by bringing out as many
as three movies in one year that's what
happened in 2018 when fans were treated
to Black Panther Avengers infinity war
and ant-man and the wasp whether the
series has taken us to space other
dimensions unknown countries or the
microscopic quantum realm it's all been
accelerating toward endgame which has
been described as a conclusion of sorts
to the MCU staggering story arc about
the all-powerful Infinity stones that
Thanos has been inside my head for six
years that story ending should provide a
natural reason to put things on pause
maybe just to take a second and count
all the money the series has made
considering the 2 billion dollar
box-office performance of Avengers
infinity war which you may recall ended
in a devastating cliffhanger it's all
but guaranteed that the fourth Avengers
will be among the biggest releases of
all time capping off a decade plus of
unprecedented runaway success the Spider
Man sequel taking the webslinger out of
America for the first time for a
European tour with Mysterio also seems
poised to do big numbers so 2020 looks
like the perfect time for Marvel to
scale things back for a little bit allow
it both creators and fans time to catch
their breath and get excited again for
new stories to come while the specifics
are still unknown to the public Marvel
Studios head honcho Kevin Feige has
offered a few general teasers for the
upcoming fourth phase of the MCU
speaking to collider during a Captain
Marvel press junket Feige teased the
all-new all-different future of the
series telling viewers to definitely
expect more obscure comic characters to
get pulled off the company's deep bench
for the feature film treatment as the
producer put it
everything after endgame and after
spider-man far from home will be
different and be unique as we try to
make every film seen returning
characters is certainly something we're
going to do and want to do but also
introducing characters that the majority
of the world has never heard of much
like guardians of the galaxy much like
Avengers before we made Avengers and
there are lots of them he continued
sharing that the film about the Eternals
is in the pipeline for the post endgame
MCU that movie he says will introduce a
whole new group of legendary heroes to
the MCU at once
Feige said we like the idea of doing an
ensemble movie from the start as opposed
to building up as we did with the first
Avengers more like guardians not totally
but in terms of introducing a new group
of people he also left open the
possibility for a movie with epic scope
taking audiences far back into the past
of the MCU saying Jack Kirby did an
immense amazing epic with eternals that
spans tens of thousands of years and
that's also something we haven't really
done which is why that among many other
things post endgame we find appealing
while Marvel may be taking a short pause
from theatrical releases we can still
expect new content in an intriguing move
the studio is developing several
television series set in the MCU to
launch on Disney's upcoming streaming
platform Disney Plus unlike the Netflix
or ABC series which are produced by
Marvel television these shows will be
full-fledged Marvel Studios productions
featuring movie characters and sporting
big budgets the series lineup includes a
show about Tom Hiddleston's trickster
god Loki which is expected to premiere
later in 2019 also reportedly in the
works are a team-up series with Falcon
in the Winter Soldier and another
project centering on vision and Scarlet
Witch rumor has it that there may even
be a project in the pipeline centering
on Clint Barton's Hawkeye training Kate
bishop his eagle-eyed successor so rest
easy true believers work
more Marvel content than we know what to
do with all it's going to take is just a
little bit of patience there are some
movies we know the company is working on
including eternals Black Widow and
sequels the Black Panther Doctor Strange
and the guardians of the galaxy but when
these movies will officially appear is
still up in the air but Feige has
assured fans that the company has a
slate of movies ready to go all the way
up through 2025 who could we be seen in
the future miss Marvel the Thunderbolts
or could we soon start seeing Marvel
Studios take on x-men and the Fantastic
Four the possibilities feel limitless
but before we can get to all of that
we've got business to take care of with
Thanos it may be the end of an era but
it's also the start of something new
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stuff or coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]